hi my name is Gotham and I'm from cells
which is solar energy research instead
of Singapore and we are here to present
doc on America how we are using it to
deploy all our Center face international
programs thank you hi my name is Dalia
swirl and from the solar energy resource
in Singapore today I am going to present
how we use Burma's particular tool to
create rest api's which are used as
simulation tools in our peak ability
so good afternoon this talk focuses on
an ongoing project at our Research
Institute which is the development of a
online simulation platform wolfram
product Mathematica is used quite
extensively in this project specifically
the web Mathematica tool to create web
services that I used as a back-end to
our online simulation platform and this
talk we'll talk on the both aspect of
this development basically the
development of the web services and the
software architecture behind the online
simulation platform itself so let me
allow to give you an outline of this
talk I'll be giving you a background
information of this overall project then
I'll move on to explain the vision we
had for this platform the approach we
took to achieve that vision and how
Mathematica exactly comes into picture
then I'll move on to explain the API
development methodologies and the
various web services we have developed
for the different use cases we have in
our community then Gotham would be
taking on this talk and he will give you
a detailed overview of the excel hetro
web simulation platform itself followed
by a demo of how the website looks and
feel for an end user so the photovoltaic
community is one of the major driving
forces for the global spike in awareness
towards the use of renewable energy it
has the highest installation capacity
and the steepest learning curve across
all the renewable energy sources
still the usability of a solar cell is
bottleneck by its efficiency and its
cost factor and a large volume of
research in the PV community utilizes
simulation programs and modeling tools
to understand its material and physical
properties but this approach has some
challenges associated with them these
simulation programs are basically
written in a variety of different
programming languages there is no set
standard to communicate between them and
they require a bit of training before
one can start using them also there is a
lack of any type of centralized database
in the PV community to which a
researcher can upload their measurement
data the PV community is also lagging
behind in exposure to modern
computational concepts such as machine
learning and data analytics that they
can perform over the large data set they
already have then there are there are
expensive and complicated licensing
mechanism associated with the use of
these simulation programs which provides
a hindrance to use of them for a
researcher or a PhD student now this
this problem can be solved easily if
these features this simulation program
capability and data analytic models are
available through a single platform the
Solar Energy Research Institute of
Singapore is working on such a project
which brings together these feature in a
cohesive manner
cerise is the National Institute for
solar energy research in Singapore and
for the past decade we have developed a
lot of simulation programs and we also
have access to many characterization and
processing tool in our clean rooms so in
a sense we have a data set which is
composed of both real measurements as
well as simulation data set so the
platform I just talked before which
brings together these features let's
suppose it's a web-based platform then
it makes even more easier for a
researcher to do simulation tasks online
as well as to upload their data to a
centralized database so with this
motivation the development of our online
web simulation platform was started and
to understand the project you have to
consider is four main layers first is
the user interface which is the only
part accessible to the end-user through
which they can do simulation tasks they
can upload measurements or they can
provide inputs for these simulation or
measurement programs then there are
micro services dedicated for performing
individual tasks and that's where when
Mathematica comes into picture because
it allows us to develop these kind of
micro services for doing specific
simulations or creating programs to
upload data or to do data analytics also
with the modern machine learning
capabilities in the latest m'sieur
Mathematica version also we have a
centralized database to which the user
can upload a measurement data coming
from a processing or a characterization
tool and this database is further
divided into process database
measurement data base and solar cell
architecture database the last phase of
the project would then be to deploy
machine learning tools and data analytic
models over the last data set collected
through such an interface so for this
interface the vision we had was it
should be easy to access the development
for this platform should be easy for
developers who want to put their web
services on this platform the end user
student access the source code of any
individual simulation programs and also
as it's a website the computational
resources allocated for a single
execution should be kept minimalistic
and we are in a learning curve so the
development methodology should be
flexible enough for future amendments so
the approach we took to achieve this
kind of vision was to convert all our
use cases
to individual application programming
interfaces the reason being these API is
provide us on-demand computation and
they are individual endpoints so they
can be configured to run in a parallel
or pipelining manner example where
pipelining concept is useful in our
context is let's suppose user wants to
upload the data from a characterization
tool doing current-voltage profiling of
a solar cell they can use an API API
number one we just converts this data to
a standard JSON object that can be saved
in a database very easily or can be fed
into another API which is tasked to do
some post-processing on this data to get
some additional parameter useful in our
context so I've talked about the vision
we had the approach we took to achieve
this vision now how exactly Mathematica
comes into picture so using Mathematica
you I can create web services that I've
just talked now these api is also
results from web math media can be
returned in format of a string that is
in turn can be structured as a JSON
object which can be understood by your
online simulation platform to be stored
in a database or to be post processed on
by another further API also many
simulation programs were already
developed using Mathematica at our
Research Institute so it was quite easy
to convert directly them to a web
service in this section I'm going to
talk about the API development
methodologies and the various web
services we have developed so far so all
our api's are kept in a series where
Mathematica server and our simulation
server connects to these API through the
Tomcat servlet engine so the request URL
from our simulation platform contains
the query variables which are basically
the inputs for any simulation program or
data upload program and the results are
structured in a standard JSON object
which is in turn particular very
standard for a different type of
measurements and simulation so how an
API endpoint looks on a browser is like
this so basically this one is tasks to
just upload current-voltage data coming
from a characterization tool
it needs some inputs such as the path of
the file generated from the
characterization to let us suppose a
excel file and some more inputs so just
we save time I've filled in these inputs
so this path can be a network path or a
local path and that's how actually had
to can consume these kind of api's so
once I click
I get a Jason which contains the same
current voltage data but now in a very
structured manner so that it can be
saved in a database or can be operated
on further also the lot of inputs you
see here are basically classified into
two parts one which is provided by the
simulation platform itself like user ID
or execution time and others like
specific to a simulation program or data
upload program like in this case the
thickness of the wafer of which
current-voltage profiling has been done
so back to our program the various api
is we have be classified on the basis of
the tasks that they do so one such class
of api's are those which are used to
just upload data from individual
characterization and processing tool and
they are fairly simple to develop
because all they do is to just upload
the data exception being the applause of
upload of images photoluminescence and
electroluminescence images these images
provided by our imaging tool are in a
rhotic format and then they need certain
further post-processing to be calibrated
to a color scale and using Mathematica
we can allow an user to choose on a
scale minimum and maximum PL count
values through which they can do some
introspection of the image to find out
certain traits in a peel image so in
case of a PL image they can find out
measurement artifacts like these coil
rings or in case of an electro
luminescence image they can find out
characteristics like broken finger so
these are things that are really helpful
for a researcher in a PV community so
this was the class of API which starts
to do just upload of data there's
another class of API which is tasks to
simulate this is transpose simulations
and we have a lot of these kind of API
is some of them are developed using
Mathematica notebooks some of them uses
desktop simulation programs some of them
uses models which are written in
Centaurus design environment or synopsis
design environment and in the PV
community people still use Excel based
calculators so we wanted to have that
capability also that people can without
downloading the actual excel sheet they
can connect to it virtually using web
Mathematica and do some macro based
calculations so the simplest one is the
one which is developed in Mathematica
notebook a user can just researcher at
our research since you just follow
certain rules and syntax is that we
provide an internal wiki and they
convert their Mathematica notebook
directly to a web web service that can
be
that is ready to be integrated on our
simulation platform then there are
desktop simulation program these are
executable Windows programs that we
wanted to have an access through web
services so the methodology here is to
run these command-line executable
programs through where Mathematica where
the inputs for these simulation program
are provided by the user and mapped on
to these to the inputs of this
command-line programs through web
Mathematica and the results are then
rendered back in a JSON format which
makes it easy to be saved on a database
as well as to be sewn in to the user in
format of a table or a graph so already
we have converted many established
simulation program in the PV community
like PC 1d griddler and Coker again
there are many models which are
computationally expensive and I kept on
a discrete server like many device and
process simulation programs are written
in synopsis design environment and we
wanted to have the capability to run
these simulation through Mathematica Web
Services so the methodology here is to
map in the inputs from the user to a
pre-written cell script and to send this
cell script to the Centaurus server
through SSH protocol once the execution
is done on the sent or a server results
are fetched back to our web Mathematica
server and can be then rendered in
format of adjacent to be saved in a
database or to the zone to the user the
last case of simulation api's are those
which basically opens the excel sheet
virtually using mathematical link for
excel library and paste the data on
which computation has to be done on this
virtually opened excel sheet then we
have a visual basic code written in that
excel sheet which watches a particular
cell or column to be filled and then it
initiates the macro through which
computation has to be done once the
computation is done the results are fest
back to where Mathematica and can be
then shown to the user so the last phase
of the project as I have talked before
was to do some data analytics for the
data we can collect by deploying such
kind of api's so we are yet not at that
stage we'll be launching the website in
six more months but just as a proof of
concept if we wanted to test how good
our mathematic has built in machine
learning models and prediction tools and
whether they can be useful in the
present scene only
so we used a simulation API which is
tasked to do boron tube diffusion
process so in the PV community it is
understood but you can consider it as a
black box where the inputs are the
process conditions that are maintained
inside this tube and the output is a
diffusion profile which can be
characterized by these two parameters so
we wanted to check that whether
Mathematica can build us a prediction
model where we just provide the desired
surface concentration and Jennsen depth
for our diffusion profile and whether it
can predict the process condition that
can lead us to such kind of diffusion
profile the first step was to create a
training database we ran this simulation
program in a batch manner by
statistically varying these input
process parameters so we were left with
around 4,000 points that's a quite small
number of data points but still it was a
proof-of-concept and the parameters that
we were really interested in where the
six process parameters and the two
output characteristics to keep things
even more simple we use the demonstrated
reduction method in Mathematica to
reduce this six process parameter to one
dimension so that in our prediction
model we were left with three parameters
only to deal with now with the
prediction model ready we can ask it
that I want a junction depth of 0.45
micron since the surface concentration
of 1.5 in 19 my diffusion profile on my
solar cell what should be the process
condition that that should be maintained
in the boron tea chamber so it will
return us with the reduced set of
parameter which we can expand it back to
the original six process parameter using
the same function as we did for reducing
them now to check how good our
prediction was we fed this predicted
parameters back into the original
simulation program and did a comparison
between the desired values and the one
obtained through the prediction so in
this graph you basically see on the
x-axis the depth points in the wafer and
the on the y axis you see concentration
on those depths points so in a sense we
I asked it that I want 0.45 micron of
Junction depth but through prediction I
got actually around 0.5 2 microns but
this goes on to say so that the we used
even we used only the synthetic data but
still the accuracy is quite good and
with real data coming soon with the
launch of this website we may be able to
do some good prediction using
Mathematica
well as using Python based models and
this is something which can be really
useful in the industrial as well as for
ad me I use cases so with this one I'll
wrap up my talk and Gotham will explain
how the X solar hydro web web simulation
platform consumes these kind of API is
for an end user to deal with okay so
great so we just saw that rahul told
about all these simulation programs all
these upload programs post-processing
programs they can be converted back into
restful web services so when so now we
need to understand that so we talk about
web based platform which we are building
and the main features of this is
basically four main features the very
first thing is providing a secure access
authentication authorization role bit
success
second thing is dynamic API management
for all externally hosted web services
so which in this case is all the web
mathematica api's queuing mechanism all
sort of stuff second the third one is
basically access to all the dynamic and
export database so this is generated by
all the research scientists research
fellows PhDs and all sort of other
people in the photovoltaic context
material database architecture database
measurement database process database
and the last point is basically create
and provide access to all the big data
for training machine learning models in
the future and then putting them back as
another restful api in the system so
these are the kind of different features
which which makes XO Loretto a little
bit more interesting now to understand
what is the soleus the software
architecture the first thing we need to
understand is who are the users of the
software so we under defined three
different user types the very first one
is basically the expert database
creators so the scientists researchers
PhDs and also and so on so they would
put all their knowledge information in
the system
the second guys will be the developers
developers are like Rahul they really
are passionate about understanding how
bussines work how simulation programs
work on top of an expert database so
they can upload all their programs back
the third people are those people which
are called researchers these are
basically process engineers working in
cleanroom and factories in different
environments they do not understand much
about how these programs work because
what they are really interested in
uploading the measurement getting the
right graphs and use them to compare and
see how the progress is going on so
let's just understand from the mass user
perspective which is the researchers how
will they use the system so you can see
from the bottom it's the you can use the
web browser they can go through the
firewall use authentication do
authorization select the tool they are
working on and then select architecture
the system will know which program
they're talking about which operation
they're talking about and then we'll go
and query the Mathematica restful the
the management system and figure out ok
this is the API we're talking about
we'll go and talk to it
cue it get the response pack and handle
it and show it to the researcher what
the researcher is now gonna see is the
graph which they're interested in so
when says when they think this is the
right kind of visualization of their
measurements or the simulation programs
we can just say back in the personalized
measurement database which is a kind of
a value addition to their personalized
database ok so before we talk about the
researcher panel we need to understand
what we have uploaded back in the last
three years so we've been developing
this project for about three years now
and what we have added is nineteen
materials sixty-seven solar cell
architectures ten different measurement
schemas a bunch of programs basically
five upload measurement restful api is
five simulation restful api is about
three post processing programs which
work on top of the upload and the
simulation program and then one machine
learning model just as a proof of
concept that okay we can deploy this and
we can go on but then what we aim to go
is create a researcher interface where
basically all this deployed expert
knowledge all this different API is
which which does processing and
simulation give access to the guys in
the clean rooms or in the factory
environments so how do we do this we
create a researcher interface which is a
very straightforward simple interface
has simple eyes like five clicks and
you're all data is in and then you can
simply use it for all your performance
metrics and other stuff so yes we are in
Student Development we are still doing
this test internally inside our company
environment so but next six months we'll
be done with the beta test and we'll
move out to try it out for different
institutes and then maybe
even though the industry in the future
okay
so so I have two demonstrations the very
first demonstration is basically how
integration of your API on the etc so
basically if you were a developer like
Raul then you want you to upload your
program back to etc how will you do this
the second concern the second
demonstration is more like a live demo
where I will say in that okay I've
uploaded certain program under the etc
and then I'm a researcher I want to
consume this on my daily day to day use
case and then we will talk about a
little bit of conclusion so before yeah
before we do we can so before I go to
the first demo I would like to show you
the expert database we are having in the
system so these are all the 19 materials
we have in the system all these
materials are all dynamic they can be
scaled yes we do in context of solar at
the moment but this is all material
science you can add it to any sort of
field you want so that's that's the
message here then there were engineers
and research fellows which took these
materials and build solar cell
architectures on top of it like how a
solar cell is made different layers of
materials and then what are the
properties of each material to fit in so
that they can work together to create a
nice optimized solar cell so this is you
can see there's about 67 of these
different solar cells which we do inside
our Institute so these are like a bunch
of them so there's about 100 more which
are coming in next few months and then
the last step is once we have uploaded
the Arceus the architectures the next
step is adding a program as a developer
so I will go through the process of how
to upload it but these are generally all
the programs in the system so there's an
IV diffusion profile spectral response
you can see all sort of standardized
solar contacts measurement tools also
the simulation programs the Pocket PC 1d
and then all precipitous post-processing
programs and even though machine
learning program is wrong so without
further ado a demonstration on the video
so so in this what you can see is on the
left hand side this is the same API
where Mathematica API which is locally
there on my system and what I'm trying
to do is I'm trying to be
get uploaded back to exonerate row so
I'm going a little bit fast forwarded
I'm gonna show you I'll just go to the
ex solar hetero yeah okay I'll go to the
silver hetero I will fill up as simple
as a form and what I will do is I will I
will put all the information of my web
mathematica API endpoint where this host
tree the version number the details the
name and all the other information
basically all the input and the output
information which I expect from this
very mathematical API so my etc platform
has got a curate I do a quality control
check on the input and the output and
will ensure okay this is correct this is
in context of my solar outcome and this
is something we just and rice and of
course I get our collaborators which can
later on access this information and
then okay then I'm going to go a little
bit more fast here okay so I'm gonna add
okay maybe I'll show you okay then I'm
gonna add an operation so this operation
is basically what I want to do on this
measurement so for example here I'm
trying to do an IB upload and inside I
want to get the current voltage profile
so I will add all the input parameters
and then what this will do is this will
basically call the API on the web
Mathematica endpoint okay and then we
get a graph okay this crowd getting a
graph means the quantity check has
passed and you can save this rule back
so what we have got here is basically
all ya a quality version of our API so
idea is working we can add it back to
the system so yeah so you can see the
expected graph is basically something
like this so if you get a graph like
that we are actually good to go the
second demo I'm gonna do a quick demo is
basically use the website as a
researcher now not as a developer and
try to use this uploaded information and
upload my daily measurements so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna choose go to
upload button I will choose my tool
which is a via blabs this is a specific
kind of a tool which we added it will go
and check the cell it knows which
architecture I'm talking about so it
will show me a photo of that so I know
okay this is what I'm talking about
I will just select my file and what I'll
do is
simply upload and then once the system
has been uploaded it has been added to
my queue but now I do not know it's
correct or wrong so the next step for
mid for me is basically to confirm this
measurement so what I'll do is I call I
click this button and what has happened
here is the real time the system knew
which were met emitting a pair to call
it true back me the graph which is kind
of correct now so what I can do is now I
can just confirm this measurement and
this is now saved into my personalised
database now this is very valuable to
process engineers and the people who
work in the factories because what they
can do is now their own personalized
database which they can curate and they
can simply compare they can know their
progress and all sort of different stuff
in an environment inside a factory and
moreover they can also use it to create
machine learning guitar training data
for your machine learning models so
that's the direction we are trying to go
into so yeah so what is the conclusion
we have the conclusion we have is we
have a reality in the capability of
uploading measurements using restful web
services so we support all the
standardized characterization tools at
the moment inside the solar context
capability to execute simulation
programs as restful web services and
then here we support command line tools
pull from base tools
server based tools excel based
calculators and the capability to manage
these restful api services in a photo
voltic and context and then also have
the capability to integrate machine
learning models on top of it so at some
point we will have a lot of data and we
can use all the awesomeness of their
mecha of Mathematica to build machine
learning models on top of it and of
course now we on the state of building
this interface for upload measurement
simulation measurements and soon we'll
have the machine learning model so
that's pretty much it from our side
thank you very much
you
[Applause]